welcome back to las vegas now
if you have a need for speed like me
subaru's got you covered
[Music]
we have the subaru wrx and we have the
wrx
sti and they are award-winning cars
uh they are world rally championship
cars
with the wrx you have a 2-liter
boxer that is a horizontally opposed
engine the
engine lies flat in the engine bay which
is actually a great
safety feature as well as it promotes
an incredible handling to that the the
center of gravity in the vehicle's lower
so that's 268 horsepower
or if you want to go to the grand daddy
sti that's 310 horsepower because it's a
2.5 liter
direct injected engine so burton i don't
want to touch it but i heard
that this is your new baby this is my
new baby is right
wow so introduce us this is cool so this
is the new 2020 subaru wrx
sti and it is a high performance
subaru that is not only safe but it is a
whole lot of fun to drive
i can imagine so what's it like when
you're on the road in this
well you really feel uh in command i
mean it's got a lot of power
and also you have that feeling of safety
i mean it's a subaru
you know and you know with the with the
amazing technology that they put into it
you have the the starlink safety and
security system
so you know if something were to happen
you're automatically connected uh
to an operator who's gonna say do you
need help uh it also
is great if you need to remotely start
your car
or even locate your car oh that's good
that's good to know
now when you're out on the road people
are looking in like
oh you're so cool what kind of reactions
do you get when driving this car
so i'm i'm getting a lot of people
especially younger ones they'll come
alongside they'll give me a thumbs up
or they'll come alongside and they'll
want to maybe see what the car can do
a little bit rev it up a little bit well
speaking of revving up can i get inside
the car
absolutely i want to see the interior
that's my favorite part
those are designed recaro seats
this is so nice tell me about the
advanced technology on the inside
so you have as we already stated the the
starlink safety and security you also
have a beautiful
infotainment system there with satellite
radio
am fm stereo amazing speakers i'm
imagining the music oh
yeah you can you can rock out while
you're driving down the road
i love it okay i know this is i know
you've been driving him for a couple
months
but have we named him yet we haven't
named it yet what are you thinking
okay well the color is just beautiful
it reminds me of a superhero so i'm
going for
blue flash blue flash i love it i love
it
as long as i don't see that in the
rearview mirror
blue flash call subaru of las vegas at
702-495-2100
or visit subaru of las vegas dot com
check out their
a lot to love event now through march
31st they're offering
zero percent apr financing on select
2021 models
for well-qualified buyers las vegas now
we'll be right